Labour leader has attracted a group of
teenage admirers who are identifying
themselves online as Milly fans well
online BuzzFeed has picked up on this
phenomenon with me is one of their
writers Hana DOOL welcome to you let's
have a look at this first of all this
all started with ABI who described
herself as a spokesman of Milly fandom
and she said I'm just an exam stress 17
year old who loves Tom Hiddleston and
thinks the media is unfair to aides just
wanted to change that were you surprised
when you saw this phenomenon appearing I
was a bit so I saw a bee after a few
weeks of stalking ed miliband fans
online I don't know if any of you
noticed but during the first leaders
debate there were a lot of people coming
out of the woodwork who claimed to be
sexually attracted to Ed Miliband we
thought this was funny and started
following these people admitted I was
obviously quite pleased as well until a
be delighted you've joined labour
welcome I should say that Abby said she
couldn't join us tonight because she's
taking her aske levels and she don't
even any levels yeah guys another one so
basically what happened here is a bunch
of teenage girls created what's called a
fandom around ed Miliband which is when
online teens they don't have to be teens
they don't have to be girls but this was
definitely led by teen girls decide that
they love ed Miliband in the style of
loving Zayn Malik for example
so they've this trended overnight it
really went mad and with a lot of a lot
of people were confused about this but
what I think they don't understand is
that they don't love him necessarily as
a sexy icon which some papers have
suggested but more as a dorky relatable
cute scruffy man now we've also had cool
Ed Miliband as well Miliband which is
people adapting pictures I don't think
we've got any of those oh here we are
cool Ed Miliband adapted pasted areas as
David Beckham and here he is as James
Bond so this is this is not done by the
same team girls that I've been chatting
to you today but this is I think
indicative of a similar current of
enjoying Ed Miliband as an underdog
figure
and projecting him as this cool guy
which started out funny because it seems
so untrue but now has strangely become
true as the irony slips away well indeed
here's Elly this all started out as a
joke but now I think I legitimately
fancy ed miliband
yeah I love all these girls because they
are so funny and they're also very
politically in tune they know what
they're doing and they know that they're
strangely powerful they've been very
surprised by this and very over the moon
by the attention but they they care
about politics actually and they've been
telling me about this all day about how
they care about tuition fees and they
care about the high housing crisis so
even though they can't vote
they are strangely kingmakers in a way I
should say not there are others who want
to be in on this they've started
something called camera nets people who
fantasy David Cameron but a little bit
of suspicion about that but the camera
Nets was I believe it was started by an
actual teen fan who was trying to fight
back against the Millar fan but it
doesn't have the same ring to it it is
trending right now but it's because so
many people are making fun of it that
they they're not taking it what people
suggesting that the camera that are in
fact dad's army yeah and here we have it
someone the boy who slept say there's a
big difference between an organic social
media trend and a cynically motivated
counter-attack is that I don't I don't
know if it was cynically motivated I
think that some teens really do love
David Cameron but I it doesn't have the
same humor and yeah spread as a lot of
these girls have thousands and thousands
of followers on Twitter now five years
ago of course there was a big heartthrob
who was someone else Nick Clegg and
there we got it Nick Clegg came into my
work today and I'm now convinced the
Liberal Democrats are going to shake up
the two-party system Clegg mania so is
it just a question of being the person
that young people finding easiest to
identify with you think I think with
edits that he there has been this
program to paint him as this awkward
nerds basically and so right now is that
he's the underdog and so there might be
some of that that relates to collect
mania but it remains to be seen what
happens to the Millican what do you
think I mean it may be a pretty thin
choice but do you think Miliband is the
most attractive of the lead
I'd say so I met him in real life once
and and he was better in real life and
on TV let me just say that okay
well not keep very much Adi there he is
obviously impressed with that verdict
he's a bit embarrassed by at all I think